c'mon as a nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that uh prayers will solve all
of the we default in the world
so the helping on your journey today
we're going to talk about how you can
stay calm in stressful situation will
number four is my personal favorite that
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the back and as always as you're
watching here's hoping that prison greta
Hsu please leave it down below the book
goes around other things that we aspire
Michael enterprise to and else will be
write it down much more likely to stick
for yourself Islam
[Music]
I know without a question then one of
most important decisions you'll make in
your entire lifetime is the better
handle stress to decide your identity
and who you are anymore you're not going
to be as stressed as you were last year
or the year before we should all become
more peaceful more thoughtful more
present more joyous people as we age
would you not agree and if that's true
then it's time to start now
we number one is have a schedule one of
the things that really helped me stay
calm with all those things that were
happen in my business was to have a
schedule and I know that there's a time
for the thing that is causing an issue
and so for example Tuesday is my YouTube
dates when I review all the videos from
my team it's when I answer any questions
when I do setups for collaborations when
I'm doing the research anything
basically YouTube related except for
filming I do on a Tuesday and so
whenever I get emails during the week I
get questions I get proposals I get
ideas I review a video that then spawns
another creation I have a place I put it
in my folder and I know on Tuesday I'm
going to have time to go out and do it
and I think oftentimes when we don't
have time to figure it out we try to
rush to solve it it creates chaos it
creates stress but knowing that you have
a place in your calendar to be able to
do it for me at least creates a great
sense of calm when I have a difficult
day here's one of the first things I do
I will get on my mountain bike and I
will ride like a bat out of wherever
through the forest and that releases
dopamine in my brain which is the
neurotransmitter of inspiration and that
releases serotonin moving right on the
bicycle it releases serotonin which is
the pleasure neurotransmitter and it
cuts down on my cortisol which is the
fear hormone so just simply going for a
mountain bike ride or going for a swim
or getting into yoga class or something
as simple as going for a walk or maybe
even doing jumping jacks when no one's
looking will create a pharmacy of
mastery within your brain which will
affect your psychology your neurobiology
and your interior life which makes you
just feel a lot better you know that
after a workout you always feel
different than you did before you went
into the work and related to a pharmacy
of mastery is something that I have
counted on for years what I've had good
seasons when I've had challenging
seasons of my life massage I call it the
to massage protocol to massages every
single week it moves your lymph it moves
your blood which oxygenate your system
it reduces toxicity you
a whole lot better you know there has to
be an intentional decision at some point
in our lives where you say look I'm not
going to be distressed anymore I'm
allowing too much stress into my life
and please notice the words I'm using
here I'm allowing too much stress into
my life most stress is not going to go
real no one hands you a plate of stress
it's not something you see and we can
transact in exchange it's something we
make up in our mind we make things
stressful that may or may not be or have
any cause to be stress inducing you know
one thing that could stress you out
might not be a stressful thing to
anybody else so that proves we're making
it up and since we're making it up we
should decide what we're going to do in
the future are we going to always be
stressful people or not I know that
sounds so silly but I made that decision
when I was young I was 20 years old and
I said look I don't want to be a
stressful person anymore
I used to stress about getting
everything right and getting good grades
I stressed about you know pleasing
people and stress about did I fit in I'd
stressed about college and stressed
about and sometimes all this is made up
you know matter of fact most stress is
coming from usually one of two things
first is a false time crunch that we
perceive we think we only have so much
time so everything becomes starts oh my
god I get this done I got this not I got
this done and we're reacting our lives
to really false deadlines someone asks
you for something you think you have to
get it to them right away
you probably don't it's probably not a
real deadline and unless you ask them
when is the real deadline on this I mean
the point in which everything crumbles
and falls apart if you don't get it then
what would happen what is the worst
thing that would happen if you didn't at
that exact time I'm crazy about this in
my life if someone says well Brendan I
need this by Thursday I say okay if you
need it by Thursday is Thursday the day
everything would explode and fall apart
if you didn't get it and they're like no
I mean no Monday would be fine and I
just bought myself Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday and part of day Monday I
just bought five
by asking when the real deadline is
because most people they say they want
something from you when they want it
not when they need it so your job to
help deal with just the time crunch that
stress can feel like is asking when is
the real deadline and all these things
that you're stressed out about do they
really need to be handled right now this
immediate second would it be okay if
you've created a plan and you hammer
them over the next couple of days next
couple weeks next couple months when you
actually realize the unbelievable amount
of time we all have as humans and how
much more time we have we become focused
diligent intentional discipline then
we're not so much stressed anymore it's
like I will get to that when the time is
appropriate for that before that I've
got other things are you going to sort
of five-point plan anyone can follow to
get over stress and trauma in the last
summit really well I think it for
someone is one thing clear the quality
of your life is the quality of where you
live emotionally but we all have a home
angry people find a way to get angry
even if their life doesn't they'd be
angry about we can always find that sad
people find what have you sad caring
people find a way to care for other
people so one thing that I identify is
where are you living what's your home
what's your habit and then the way to
change it is when I was homeless
literally on my own just getting started
I didn't have the internet but I decided
I had to go to a library and I had to
feed my mind and I always tell people
the first stage is you know weeds grow
automatically one of my teachers taught
me is that every day stand guard is the
door of your mind and scene it's
something good because if your worst
enemy puts sugar in your coffee here
you're fine if your best friend by
accident trying to help you put some
strychnine you're dead so if you feed
your mind every day 30 minutes a day of
reading something hearing something
second you got to strengthen your body
and the reason Pierce is fear is
physical right so is stagnation so is
numbness so sadness that so is rage and
when you go in and change your body by
an intense workout or a runner you can
intense walk and the blood flowing
through you science is shown it
instantly changes your biochemistry and
now your mind and body you're working
together
third thing all these people did in
common if you watch they found a mission
bigger than themselves yeah something
that they want to aspire to that was
worth more than their pain and then the
fourth thing is
to find a role model you know you heard
it with Nick almost anybody finds a role
model that makes it real I was with
Warren Buffett and with Sara Blakely the
youngest billionaire we did this
roundtable about the future and when you
listen this woman and when women need
her they will just love Spanx or product
that made her a billionaire they love
this woman because she's a role model of
what's possible you get a role model it
becomes real to you if you get a plan
you get a goal plan and you take massive
action and the last step number five
there's always somebody all our stuff
than you are and care what you've done
so if you can go help somebody worse off
it puts your life in perspective and it
also reminds you life's not about me
it's about we I always tell people the
secret to a great life the secret to
living is giving and there's when you
realize or something you still to give
even if you lost your legs even if
you've been through a horrific financial
situation your life can improve but more
importantly you'll have a meaningful
life because your life will contribute
to the people there's a ton of bad days
being an entrepreneur not to mention 98%
of entrepreneurial ventures are going to
fail so there's gonna be a really bad
day in your future you know hopefully
not for you I'm sure any of you you know
for me I don't know I think it's a very
personal question I think it's how
you're wired I'm so all-in entrepreneur
I prefer the pain I think one of the
reasons I love the jet so much is
because they bring me so much pain you
know I I love the climb to me the
setback is exciting I love when
something goes wrong it's where I shine
the most but that's not for everybody
right I mean it could be very difficult
and when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and all the other
things it can get real nasty to me the
way I handle things even though the few
rare days when I really struggle I take
a real step back and make pretend that
somebody called me and told me that my
mother or daughter were killed and I
know that's very dark and I apologize
but it's really what I do I literally am
able to at my deepest most struggling
moment within business take a step back
and remind myself that I can make a
trillion dollars tomorrow on Bitcoin
that and if something bad happened to
the people I love the most that it would
mean nothing and it very consistently
rewires me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's money
for me it's not really money it's my
legacy so I get hurt by it a little bit
more um but uh yeah I mean it's you know
I put in perspective its money and you
know what up until I have daughter even
while I was married Apple to what I have
neasha four years ago
I secretly wanted to lose all my money I
had this weird twisted dark fantasy of
losing everything just to rise again
like a phoenix and remind me
thank you guys so much for watching I
love to know what do you think of this
video what did you take from it that
you're going to immediately apply to you
like for bigger businesses somehow
please share favorite and comment below
I'm really excited to see what you have
a lamentable chance investing pro making
soldiers be than otherwise healthier
ones words and taking the picture and
post with your Twitter account I will
reach in this department and it's so
glad that you joined us well thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you those who continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one were is
much loved have an amazing day
fold your eyes and breathe this sounds
like a pretty basic one but just just
reminding yourself that there's a
stressful I'm going to breathe I'm going
to close my eyes I'm going to relax as
things start to get better why do people
go outside for a smoke like the nicotine
health but it's also the breathing and
so if there's a reminder on your
calendar or something on your desktop
background or whenever you feel that
stress coming on board just reminding
yourself I'm going to close my eyes I'm
going to take a couple deep breaths I
really feel a little bit more calm
anxiety usually is coming from just
three places and once you realize it
it's not so scary anymore the scary part
about anxiety is when you don't know why
you have it and again for some people
they might have a chemical imbalance
they might have a challenge or a past
unconscious traumatic event that is
coming up for them and they might need
to seek some help for it others can just
sit down and go okay where is this
coming from
and knowing that's probably coming from
three places that now we can deal with
it most anxiety comes from fear of loss
you feel like in any uncertain situation
you feel like gosh if I don't do well
here I might lose reputation I might
lose my job I might lose someone's
respect or somebody's love I might lose
something I like if I try something new
and it doesn't go well it's just scared
there might lose something so ask
yourself next time you feel anxiety what
am i scared on there lose here what
could I be scared of that I'm gonna lose
here maybe that's what I needed and then
do fact-checking
thing is that legitimate is that a
concern I'm blowing up in my mind I have
no basis in reality to figure out and if
I don't I need to stop thinking about it
and I need to start focusing on what's
tangible action items I can do tomorrow
or today to take one little tiny step
closer because sometimes the easiest way
to wipe out anxiety is to get a little
momentum I would say the second thing
that people often fear is hardship they
just think the real anxiety is I'm not
going to be able to handle the
I'm not enough with the person I don't
have the skills the capabilities the
competencies the talent and if I try it
it's going to be hard on me
people say it's gonna be too hard on me
and I tell people all the time if that's
coming from that you have no idea how
strong of a human being you can be you
really don't I don't and I'm not saying
that I'm not preaching here I don't we
don't know I'm stunned at the things I
can handle today that I couldn't handle
ten years ago and I know there's areas
of your life that like to like things
that you just you can handle today when
you first tie your shoe you fear that
you're not gonna be able to figure it
out the next time it's going to be too
hard or you'll be embarrassed but then
you do it ten times and now you've got
this the hardship thing doesn't bother
you anymore
so one way to overcome anxiety is to
question where do I feel like I'm not
going to be enough or capable here and
then start doing a little diagnosis
thing but where have I been so capable
of before or how could I develop this
capability what support or mentorship
could I get to go to the next level here
to know that I'm not going to have to
handle on my own that all have real
support because sometimes what we need
to know to overcome anxiety is that will
be supported last piece I think people
really have a lot of anxiety towards a
disappointment they fear that they're
going to they could do it they could try
but maybe it doesn't turn out well and
because it doesn't turn out well they
start inventing all these reasons now
it's it's not going to turn out well
they're going to lose something and
they're going to have hardship and
they're going to feel like crap nope
they actually are fearing what they're
going to be feeling and that's the
anxiety the anxiety is actually just a
sense of oh my gosh I might not feel
good and though it caused us to feel
even worse right disappointment and so
you have to look at and say maybe I need
to change my valued of criteria maybe
this isn't about whether or not I
succeed maybe it's about whether or not
I give effort towards something is
meaningful to me maybe it's not towards
whether it turns out perfect but it's
that I began the journey that we stopped
thinking about is the destination going
to be perfect and the promised land for
us and instead we asked this question is
can I develop as a human can I just you
know what yes
maybe part of me overcoming anxiety is
getting more comfortable with the
uncomfortable not to get rid of the
anxiety but to get rid of how I'm
dealing with the anxieties to take pride
in the fact that I'm facing it I'm
dealing with it and I'm still marching
on and I think if we face it we deal
with it and we still march on we start
to really start managing that anxiety
you have greater strength in your
ability and in your body and you could
ever possibly imagine how I'll say it
all day long because you probably don't
believe it in those moments when you're
experiencing anxiety but next time you
start to experience anxiety to sit down
and say where's that coming from
am i scaring to lose something I'm
scared of hardship I'm a CR be
disappointed do any of those things have
any factual like matter to them and if
they do what am I going to do with that
energy am I going to let it stop me or
I'm going to use it as a tool to pay a
little bit more attention and to keep
momentum because I know the more
momentum I get the less anxiety I'll
have start focusing on developing your
strengths and your momentum you'll start
to experience what we call the charge
life worry beads this is not
philosophical don't worry about the you
know this is a really practical tactic
get a bunch of beads or beans or you
know whatever it is and every time
you're at your desk working and your
mind goes to a worry dump one of those
beads or beans you know a dried bean I'm
sure you can get them don't make any
excuses don't say well I don't live in a
city where I can get worry beads you can
find some kind of a being or bead isn't
interesting how worries prevent us from
taking action excuses to prevent us from
taking action and so on the second point
you just every time you your mind drifts
to a worry you drop the worry bead into
a cup or into a glass what does that do
it starts to give you an intense
awareness about how much time you spend
worrying and more particularly how many
worries you have and with more awareness
you can make more better choices and
will better choices you'll see better
results okay